en el norte de california no todos los
residentes lograron huir de las llamas
el martes las autoridades anunciaron que
al menos 4 personas murieron en el mayor
incendio del año en el estado los
equipos de búsqueda localizaron a otros
dos individuos fallecidos en el
perímetro del incendio de mckinney el
lunes ambos individuos fueron
localizados en residencias separadas a
lo largo de la ruta estatal 96 esto
eleva el número de víctimas mortales
confirmadas a 4 el incendio de mckinney
es el mayor de los incendios forestales
que arden el bosque nacional de klamath
desde que el fuego inició el viernes
arrojó cerca de 22.000 hectáreas y
destruyó a más de una decena de
edificios como aquí en el pequeño pueblo
de clavar y ver
cuando el fuego llegó a esta línea de
cresta tenía una llama de 30 metros a lo
largo de unas 5 millas y el viento
soplaba bajaba como un soplete sólido no
había nada que lo detuviera
esa es mi manera
es una comunidad pequeña
que aquí viven buenas personas buena
gente en su mayoría y con el tiempo se
reconstruirá pero va a llevar algún
tiempo hemos sido realmente devastados
estos últimos años el hueste de eeuu ha
sufrido de incendios con una amplitud y
una intensidad excepcionales lo que los
científicos atribuyen principalmente al
cambio climático a esta fecha 60 grandes
incendios forestales siguen activos en
14 estados del país